si c'est pour être infirmière fuyez pas
ce qu'il ya c'est trop compliqué
charlotte binétruy cumule 8 ans
d'expérience comme infirmière en suisse
et en france son rêve et s établir à
edmundston dans le nord-ouest du
nouveau-brunswick avec son mari thibault
et leur fils louis une proposition à
l'hôpital
mais après deux ans de démarches
administratives plus de 6000 $ de frais
et la suspension des cours de mise à
niveau nécessaires à son permis de
pratique d'infirmière elle en a assez
charlotte décide de s'installer dans la
province voisine
on va à table l'infirmière française
céline et glou amable habite moncton
depuis un an et demi et ne travaille
toujours pas dans son domaine elle
s'apprête à son tour à partir
aidez nous s'il vous plaît à être connu
et puis ça nous éviterait de penser à
partir au québec contrairement au
nouveau brunswick le québec à une
entente de réciprocité avec la france
une infirmière pu obtenir un permis de
pratique après avoir suivi soixante
quinze jours de stage au cours des
quatre dernières années cinq cent trente
deux infirmières françaises ont obtenu
un permis au québec durant la même
période
le nouveau-brunswick n'a accepté que six
formés à l'étranger tous pays confondus
une situation inacceptable selon le
premier ministre du nouveau-brunswick
qui déplore que la province ne soit pas
en mesure de fournir un service efficace
en raison des obstacles posés par
l'association des infirmières sais
combien mon sens pour moi on y est en
pénurie d'infirmières suzanne dupuis
blanchard connais bien céline et glou
amable la professeure l'engager pour un
projet avec l'université de moncton
il faut avoir un problème clair annoncé
que les jambons connell puis il faut
reconnaître les coups alors que ça soit
reconnaît à programme que ce soit des
coûts partagés
merci
c'est ce soir que céline annonce à ses
enfants qu'elle s'en va peut-être au
québec
son plan est de partir seul pour le
québec et de laisser sa famille au
nouveau-brunswick pour un temps je
constate que ça va être dur puis ça m'a
un peu et hull devoir réagir comme ça ça
sera c'est que ça va me coûter comme les
infirmières que nous avons rencontrés
avaient toutes choisi de s'établir au
nouveau brunswick elle avait été
recrutée pour leurs compétences dans le
cadre du programme des candidats de la
province l'association des infirmières
et infirmiers du nouveau-brunswick a
décliné notre demande d'entrevue
dans un courriel elle affirme que le
processus d'immatriculation est
semblable à ceux des autres provinces
canadiennes
ici nicolas steinbach radio canada à
moncton